one thing about winning and losing okay  when you're winning  you know and you win for a long time you  think you're gonna win forever and  you're not okay the thing about losing  is what  you're losing for a long time  you think you're going to lose forever  and you're not  [ __ ] can turn very quickly good and bad  so if you're overly overly optimistic  maybe drink a little parapet or no yeah  you know may not be bad for you to get a  little paranoid and if you've been  losing a little bit too much maybe it's  good you go about re buy the book norman  vincent peel the power of positive  thinking and have a drink or two of a  positive thing and see what it does for  you but regardless of what's going on  uh we don't really know exactly what's  gonna happen with the market the next  three to six 12 months